[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN PENAGOS: What's
up, Marvelites?
I'm Ryan Penagos, aka Agent M.
CHERRY RAE: And I
am Cherry Rae, games
accessibility
consultant, streamer,
and friend of Crystal Dynamics.
We are at E3 to give
fans worldwide a chance
to tour the epic Marvel's
Avengers E3 booth.
RYAN PENAGOS: Cherry,
I haven't seen anything
past what we see right here.
Can we go check it out?
CHERRY RAE: Let's go.
RYAN PENAGOS: Let's do it!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN PENAGOS: Marvel's
Avengers begins
on A-Day with Iron Man, Captain
America, Thor, Black Widow,
and Hulk unveiling a high-tech,
new Avengers headquarters
in San Francisco
including the reveal
of a brand new
helicarrier powered
by an experimental power source.
CHERRY RAE: The E3
booth is designed
to bring fans into the
world of Marvel's Avengers.
Everything from the
decor to the badge
is modeled after the
in-game A-Day experience.
You can find the booth in the
south hall at number 1601.
RYAN PENAGOS: And if
you're here at E3,
you gotta come get
your A-Day badge.
You're gonna get a checkout
time to come and see
the Marvel's Avengers demo--
30 minutes of awesomeness!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHERRY RAE: Return to the booth
during a designated time slot
to check out the official
Marvel's Avengers
costume gallery
before journeying
deeper into the helicarrier.
RYAN PENAGOS: If you watched
Marvel's Avengers E3 trailer,
and we're sure you did, you
know that the event turns
deadly when a
catastrophic accident
results in massive devastation.
Now the Avengers are
blamed for the tragedy,
and so they have to disband.
But five years later,
the world is in peril.
Superheroes are outlawed.
What's our only hope?
To reassemble earth's
mightiest heroes.
Cherry, I love all
these costumes.
I love all this, but I
want to go to the theater.
I gotta see more.
You ready?
CHERRY RAE: I am so excited.
RYAN PENAGOS: Let's do this.
CHERRY RAE: So excited.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHERRY RAE: When
your time comes,
you'll be escorted to an
exclusive first gameplay
demo for Marvel's Avengers,
which will give you
an extended look at the
explosive events of A-Day
and intel on each
of the Avengers.
RYAN PENAGOS: Before leaving,
get your official A-Day lanyard
and dossier as a souvenir of
the day that changed everything.
You can learn more
about Marvel's Avengers
and get information on the
beta at playavengers.com.
Marvel's Avengers will be
available on PS4, Xbox,
PC, and Stadia on May 15, 2020.
CHERRY RAE: We hope you enjoyed
our peek behind the scenes
at E3.
Till next time--
RYAN PENAGOS: I'm Ryan.
CHERRY RAE: I'm Cherry.
RYAN PENAGOS: And
this is Marvel.
CHERRY RAE: Your universe.